This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. Hello, you now boy! Me, sir! Yes, you're a good fella. A day is today. Today? What's Christmas Day, of course? Christmas Day.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。嗨，你现在这小子！我吗，先生？对，你是个好小伙。今天是某一天。今天？什么，当然是圣诞节啦？圣诞节。
No, you haven't missed it. It's Christmas Day and we're celebrating with two fun stories from the Illusionist, a show about language from Helen's Altman. The Illusionist is one of my all-time favorite podcasts, and I'm not just saying that because Helen'susionist is one of my all-time favorite podcasts, and I'm not just saying that because Helen's Altman is one of my all-time favorite people. It is a show about language, but it is absolutely not just for word nerds. It is 99PI-style storytelling using language as the lens to view culture rather than design.
不，你没错过。今天是圣诞节，我们用来自“幻术师”（The Illusionist）的两个有趣故事来庆祝，这是一档由海伦·奥尔特曼制作的关于语言的节目。“幻术师”是我有史以来最喜欢的播客之一，我这么说可不只是因为海伦·奥尔特曼是我有史以来最喜欢的人之一。这是一档关于语言的节目，但它绝不仅仅适合字词极客。它是99PI风格的故事讲述，以语言为镜头来观察文化而非设计。
And if you haven't discovered it yet, you are going to love it. With two festive seasonal favorites from the Ill illusionist, here's Helen's ultimate. The War on Christmas. When did that start? Upon the birth of Jesus Christ himself, when King Herod ordered all the baby boys in and around Bethlehem be killed? In 1644, when Oliver Cromwell's Puritans passed an ordinance prohibiting Christmas celebrations in England.
如果你还没发现它，你一定会爱上它。这里有来自“幻术师”的两个节日精选故事，有请海伦·奥尔特曼。“对圣诞节的战争”。这事是什么时候开始的？是在耶稣基督诞生的那一刻，当希律王下令杀死伯利恒及其周围的所有男婴时？是在1644年，当奥利弗·克伦威尔的清教徒通过法令禁止在英国庆祝圣诞节时？
In 1659, when the Massachusetts Bay colony Puritans managed an ordinance prohibiting Christmas celebrations in England. In 1659, when the Massachusetts Baycolonine Puritans managed to get Christmas Bound for 22 years for being a pagan festival, or was it in 1998 in Britain's second largest city, Birmingham? If you picked up practically any newspaper at the time, you would have read the Birmingham City Council had renamed Christmas, Winterville. Birmingham will celebrate the festive season as usual this year with Carol singing fairy lights and street entertainment, but don't call it Christmas, council officials have renamed it Winterville, in the hope of creating a more multicultural atmosphere
是在1659年，当马萨诸塞湾殖民地的清教徒设法通过了一项禁止在英国庆祝圣诞节的法令时？是在1659年，当马萨诸塞湾殖民地的清教徒成功让圣诞节被禁22年，理由它是异教节日，还是在1998年英国第二大城市伯明翰？如果你随手拿起当时几乎任何一份报纸，你都会读到伯明翰市议会已将圣诞节更名为“冬节”（Winterval）。伯明翰今年将像往常一样通过唱颂歌、挂彩灯和街头娱乐活动来庆祝节日，但别叫它圣诞节，市议会官员已将其重新命名为“冬节”，希望营造一种更具多元文化的氛围，
in keeping with the city's mix of ethnic groups. A politically correct decision to call Christmas festivities, Winterval, Council Christmas, call it Winterval. Birmingham Council, claiming it was anxious not to offend those in other faiths, renamed Christmas Winterval. A political correctness gone mad. Crazy Council Chiefs provoked outrage last night after naming Christmas festivities Winterval,
以契合该市多民族融合的特点。将圣诞节庆活动称为“冬节”是一项政治正确的决定，议会圣诞节，叫它冬节。伯明翰市议会声称，它急于不冒犯其他信仰的人，因此将圣诞节重新命名为“冬节”。政治正确走火入魔。疯狂的议会头头们昨晚在将圣诞节庆活动命名为“冬节”后引发了愤怒，
political correctness gone mad. Political correctness Winterville, political correctness gone mad. Political correctness gone mad. Churchmen believe the Winterville name is intended to avoid offending Muslims and other minorities. Political correctness gone mad. A municipal brainwave called Winterville, renaming the annual holiday and likening it to shopping rather than shepherd's.
政治正确走火入魔。政治正确冬节，政治正确走火入魔。政治正确走火入魔。神职人员认为，“冬节”这个名字旨在避免冒犯穆斯林和其他少数族裔。政治正确走火入魔。一个被称为“冬节”的市政灵感，将年度假期重新命名，并将其比作购物而不是牧羊。
Political correctness gone mad. The word Winterville has a nasty echo of communists who banned any Christian connotation in East Germany. And verily in Britain Christmas was banished. Now we sing Winterville carols and wear ironic Winterville sweaters. We hang up our Winterville stockings for farther Winterville to fill with Winterval gifts. And when we turn on the radio, we rock around the Winterval tree to these festive tunes. It will be lonely this winterval.
政治正确走火入魔。这个词“冬节”带有恶毒的呼应，就像在东德禁止任何基督教内涵的共产主义者一样。在英国，圣诞节确实被驱逐了。现在我们唱着冬节颂歌，穿着讽刺的冬节毛衣。我们挂上冬节长袜，等待圣诞老人（Winter Father）来填满冬节礼物。当我们打开收音机，我们围着冬节树伴着这些节日曲调摇摆。这个冬节将会很孤单，
With our children to home. Winterval Winterval Winterval Winterval Winterval Winterval. Yeah, that's exactly what happened. Well, it's about as true as most things that have been said about Winterval, which came about thanks to one Mike Chubb. Hi, my name is Mike Chubb. You could say that I was the one that has caused a few worries. That is wonderful. In the late 1990s, Mike Chubb was the head of events for Birmingham City Council. From our point of view, from my self,
孩子们都在家里。冬节 冬节 冬节 冬节 冬节 冬节。是的，情况确实如此。好吧，这大概和关于“冬节”的大多数说法一样真实，冬节的出现要归功于一个人——迈克·查布。嗨，我叫迈克·查布。你可以说我是那个引起了一些担忧的人。这太棒了。在20世纪90年代末，迈克·查布是伯明翰市议会的活动负责人。从我们的角度来看，从我个人来说，
I said the manager of this huge event section in Birmingham City Council, and my team of some like 30, we came up with the terminology, Winterville. It's like a port, a portmanteur word for winter and festival. I thought it was a portmanteur of winter and interval, I must say, to sort of suggest this hiatus in the year. No, it's between winter and festival. I think it's a good portmanteau, it's quite elegant. Until it became shorthand for war on Christmas with a side of political correctness gone mad, it started well enough, with Birmingham's first winter ball in 1997.
我说我是伯明翰市议会这个庞大活动部门的经理，我的团队大约有30人，我们想出了“Wintervla”这个术语。它就像一个混成词，由冬天（winter）和节日（festival）组合而成。我必须说，我曾以为它是冬天（winter）和幕间休息（interval）的混成词，用来暗示一年中的这段间歇。不，它是介于冬天和节日之间。我认为这是一个很好的混成词，相当优雅。直到它成为“对圣诞节的战争”的代名词，并附带“政治正确走火入魔”的佐色，它一开始还算顺利，伯明翰在1997年举办了首届冬节。
Events ran over several weeks and were attended by hundreds of thousands of people without complaints from the press or the populace. So it's not clear why the following years Winterval became a wincident. But it did. In November 1998, the then Bishop of Birmingham, Mark Santa, known as Inclaus, issued his Christmas message to the clergy of the diocese. It said, I wonder what madness is in store for us thise. It said, the papers got hold of it. On 8th November 1998, the Birmingham Sunday Mercury reported that the Bishop of Birmingham had condemned the City Council's attempt to rebrand Christmas. What happened then was of course all those papers. They said, this is a good way. Not much news at Christmas, is that let's use an interesting
活动持续了好几个星期，数十万人参加，没有遭到媒体或民众的投诉。所以目前还不清楚为什么第二年的冬节会变成一场“温发事件”（wincident）。但它确实发生了。1998年11月，时任伯明翰主教马克·桑特（被称为Inclaus）向教区神职人员发布了圣诞致辞。上面写着，我想知道今年有什么疯狂的事在等着我们。报纸拿到了这个消息。1998年11月8日，《伯明翰星期日水星报》报道称，伯明翰主教谴责了市议会重塑圣诞节品牌的企图。接下来发生的事当然就是所有那些报纸。他们说，这是个好主意。圣诞节期间没什么新闻，对吧，让我们用一个有趣的
story. Did you know Birmingham City Council of Council Christmas or the named Christmas Winter World? Thereafter it went mentioned riding worldwide. Pretty much the only person who didn't notice was Mike Chubb. I was so busy at the time. I didn't take any of the media for your ory at the time. It just didn't touch me at all because I literally were working 41 days nonstop. They are nights. Busy work waging the war on Christmas,
故事。你知道伯明翰市议会取消了圣诞节或者把圣诞节命名为冬节吗？此后，这事开始在全世界流传。几乎唯一一个没有注意到的人是迈克·查布。我当时太忙了。我当时没有理会任何媒体的狂热。这根本没有影响到我，因为我 literalmente（字面意思）连续41天不间断地工作。没日没夜。忙于发动对圣诞节的战争，
except that wasn't really what Mike and the council were doing during the war on Christmas. In this war, only one side turned up to the battlefield. It was the media, really, that actually took it on. People like the Daily Mail, just gone to Google and Google Winterble and just look at the organisations who are up in arms about it. They're up in arms because they've been led to believe that that's what Bury and City Council have intended. It wasn't? No. Business we've never off the page. It was part of a 41 day, if it was like a festival of events.
除了那并不是迈克和市议会在对圣诞节的战争期间真正做的事情。在这场战争中，只有一个阵营出现在战场上。真正参与其中的其实是媒体。像《每日邮报》这样的人，只要去谷歌搜索一下Wintervla，看看那些大发雷霆的机构就知道了。他们大发雷霆是因为他们被引导去相信伯明翰市议会就是这么打算的。事实并非如此？没有。业务从未离开过页面。它是一场为期41天的活动的一部分，如果它像一个节日活动的话。
But people thought you were trying to rebrand Christmas? Yes. They said it's political correctness gone mad. But actually political correctness had not gone mad. Political correctness had not even been a factor. Because the Council's events team was not trying to re-brand Christmas, it was trying to bundle together a whole lot of events occurring in the weeks before and after Christmas. Birmingham is Britain's second largest city with a very culturally and ethnically diverse population. There's a lot of stuff going on, particularly at that
但人们以为你们在试图重塑圣诞节品牌？是的。他们说这是政治正确走火入魔。但实际上政治正确并没有走火入魔。政治正确甚至都不是一个因素。因为议会的活动团队并不是在试图重塑圣诞节品牌，而是在试图将圣诞节前后的几周内发生的一大堆活动打包在一起。伯明翰是英国第二大城市，拥有非常多元化的人口文化和族裔。有很多事情正在发生，特别是在那个
time of year, hence they decided to use the marketing banner, Winterball. You see, like it does what it says on the turn. It markets a major festival at a time of the year called Winter. And there are sorts of things that happen in Winter. You know, it's a devoid of events in Winter, BBC children need, happens in Winter. You know, Chinese New Year happens in Winter, New Year's Eve happens in winter. Hanukkah, Eid, O and Christmas.
一年的那个时候，因此他们决定使用营销横幅“冬节”。你看，就像它在转盘上写的那样。它在一个叫做冬天的季节营销一个盛大的节日。冬天会发生各种各样的事情。你知道，冬天缺乏活动，BBC儿童赈灾活动发生在冬天。你知道，中国农历新年发生在冬天，除夕发生在冬天。光明节、开斋节、宰牲节和圣诞节。
Christmas lights, Christmas market, Christmas trees, Christmas carols. It was still called Christmas. You know, that particular event which included the Christmas lights switch on, was about a month for the events of a Christmas. That came under Christmas. It was turned Christmas. It had its own brochure Christmas. But unfortunately people decided not to see that. They decided that that's what the council did. Shortly after the war on Winterville erupted in the papers,
圣诞彩灯、圣诞市场、圣诞树、圣诞颂歌。它仍然被称为圣诞节。你知道，那个包括点亮圣诞彩灯的特定活动，大约是圣诞节活动的一个月前。那属于圣诞节。它被称为圣诞节。它有自己的圣诞宣传册。但不幸的是，人们选择看不到这一点。他们认定那是市议会所做的事情。在对冬节的战争在报纸上爆发后不久，
the council actually issued a statement that they were not renaming Christmas and Christmas was very visibly a major part of the Winterville lineup. But which story sticks more? The true one that Winterville was a marketing and admin umbrella or the lie that Winterville had come to kill Christmas. Nobody actually could see the simplicity of the wind or brand, but the regimen to what they wanted, to give advice to their own aspirations and prejudices. Now, personally, I've noticed significantly more uproar about the war on Christmas than actual evidence that that war is being waged. Some people seem very eager for there to be a war on Christmas, so they can leap to Christmas's defence. Though Christmas has achieved cultural dominance way beyond religious lines, to cast it as an underdog, provides a cover for taking up other cultures, and to create and maintain
市议会实际上发表了一份声明，称他们并没有给圣诞节更名，而且圣诞节非常显眼地是冬节阵容的主要部分。但是哪个故事更深入人心？是冬节是一个营销和行政伞形概念的真实谎言，还是冬节是来杀死圣诞节的谎言？没有人真正能看出冬节品牌的简单性，但他们顺从了他们想要的，去迎合他们自己的愿望和偏见。现在，就我个人而言，我注意到关于对圣诞节战争的喧嚣明显多于这场战争正在进行的实际证据。有些人似乎非常渴望发生一场对圣诞节的战争，这样他们就可以跳出来为圣诞节辩护。尽管圣诞节已经取得了超越宗教界限的文化统治地位，但把它塑造成弱者，为接纳其他文化提供了掩护，并制造和维持了
divisions in society. But Christmas is a pagan Roman Christian festival, celebrated by people from all sorts of cultures with all sorts of beliefs, including me, an ethnically Jewish atheist. Christmas is not threatened by multiculturalism. It is multicultural. People don't like change. They're scared of change. And to a certain extent, Winterhall was used as an example of a change that's gone too far because they misread what the organizers are trying to do. And they continued to misread it. After 1998, Birmingham didn't run Winterville again, but in the following years the Winterville myth was repeated dozens of times in Britain's national newspapers.
社会中的分裂。但圣诞节是一个异教的罗马基督教节日，由来自各种文化、有着各种信仰的人们庆祝，包括我这个有犹太血统的无神论者。圣诞节并没有受到多元文化的威胁。它本身就是多元文化的。人们不喜欢改变。他们害怕改变。在某种程度上，冬节被用作一个走得太远的改变的例子，因为他们误读了组织者的意图。而且他们继续误读它。1998年之后，伯明翰再也没有举办过冬节，但在接下来的几年里，冬节的神话在英国全国性报纸上被重复了数十次。
In fact, in 2011, after running another such piece, the Daily Mail had to print a retraction saying that Winterval did not rename or replace Christmas. But, too little too late, Winterval had already become the byword for political correctness gone mad. And it still continues. Just a few weeks ago, in the British Parliament, Shaleish Farah, the Conservative MP for Northwest Cambridge, told Prime Minister Theresa May. But minority communities should respect the views and traditions of mainstream Britain. And that means Christmas is not winterble, and Christmas trees are not festive trees. I do agree with my own old friend. Well we can all agree with him that Christmas is not winterble since it never was winterble.
事实上，在2011年，《每日邮报》在刊登了另一篇此类文章后，不得不发表撤回声明，称冬节并没有重新命名或取代圣诞节。但是，为时已晚，冬节已经成为政治正确走火入魔的代名词。而且这种情况还在继续。就在几周前，在英国议会上议院，西北剑桥郡的保守党议员沙利什·瓦拉（Shailish Vara）对首相特雷莎·梅说：少数族裔社区应该尊重英国主流社会的观点和传统。这意味着圣诞节不是冬节，圣诞树也不是节日树。我确实同意我自己的老朋友。好吧，我们都同意他的看法，圣诞节不是冬节，因为它从来就不是冬节。
It's so simple, it's not difficult, it's just certain people just decide to say what they want to say, maybe they want to create a bit of a stir, because it sells papers. But in a way, as a marketing story, it is very successful because the brand really clung on if you just called it, I don't know, Birmingham winter holidays, no one would. Oh yeah, yeah, I mean, yeah, absolutely. It's just unfortunate that the brand had been so misinterpreted. That's right, that's right. If you had your time again, would you do it differently?
这很简单，一点也不难，只是某些人决定说他们想说的话，也许他们想制造一点轰动，因为这能卖报纸。但从某种程度上讲，作为一个营销故事，它非常成功，因为这个品牌真的深入人心了，如果你只是叫它，我不知道，伯明翰冬季假期，根本没人会。哦，是的，是的，我是说，是的，绝对是。只是不幸的是这个品牌被严重误读了。没错，没错。如果让你重来一次，你会做出不同的选择吗？
Yeah. Good for you. People have got to experiment, they've got to introduce and the public need to be introduced to new, exciting initiatives. Because otherwise we're just going to live in a very dull society. Here's what you're gonna do. You're gonna go buy that prize turkey in the window and settle in for another story from the illusionist featuring a couple of familiar 99PI voices after this. Here again is the illusionist, not 99% invisible. So we're in the parking lot of Cow Palace. There's a gun show happening at the same time.
会。好样的。人们必须进行试验，他们必须引入，公众也需要接触到新的、令人兴奋的倡议。否则我们将生活在一个非常沉闷的社会里。接下来你要做的是：去橱窗里买下那只珍贵的火鸡，然后安顿下来，聆听“幻术师”的另一个故事，其中包含一些熟悉的99PI声音，广告之后见。再次有请“幻术师”，而不是《99%隐形》。所以我们现在在牛宫（Cow Palace）的停车场。同一时间正在举办一场枪支展。
Yeah, it says welcome patriots. We are here for the Dickensfest. Excuse me. Katie Mingle and Avery Trouffleman of 99% invisible are about to enter Victorian London. In the Cal Palace arena in Daily City, just south of San Francisco, California. It's also like 60-ish degrees. It feels not Christmasy at all. The great Dickens Christmas Fair entrance. It's a giant portrait of Santa Claus as you walk in. The Dickens Christmas Fair has been an annual event in the Bay Area since 1970,
是的，上面写着“欢迎爱国者”。我们是来参加狄更斯节的。不好意思。99%隐形的凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）和艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffelman）即将进入维多利亚时代的伦敦。位于旧金山南部加利福尼亚州戴利城的牛宫竞技场。气温大概是60华氏度左右。一点也没有圣诞节的感觉。伟大的狄更斯圣诞集市入口。一走进去就是一个巨大的圣诞老人肖像。狄更斯圣诞集市自1970年以来一直是湾区的年度活动，
founded by husband and wife team Ron and Phyllis Paterson, who previously had started the Renaissance fairs in the backyard of their home in Los Angeles. Their kids are on the Dickens Fair now. It's held on five weekends prior to Christmas and is 120,000 square feet of Victorian London festivity. Wow! They are all my goodness! Wow! They did a really good job!
由夫妇档罗恩和菲利斯·帕特森（Ron and Phyllis Paterson）创立，他们之前曾在洛杉矶家里的后院发起过文艺复兴集市。他们的孩子现在接管了狄更斯集市。它在圣诞节前的五个周末举行，占地12万平方英尺，充满了维多利亚时代伦敦的节日气氛。哇！天哪！哇！他们做得太棒了！
Okay, so it smells like apple cider or something. Spiced spicy. It's sort of set up to look like an old English like like a market or like I don't know what would you say. Yeah, they're like storefronts and right here there's a big old-timey sign that says champagne and they're like bar mids serving champagne. And there's a lot of the British, oh my god, hell in there, British flags everywhere. All along the ceiling. It looks like a film set of a street. The streets are named things like
好吧，所以闻起来像苹果酒之类的东西。香料味。它的布置看起来像是一个古老的英国市场，或者我不知道你会怎么说。是的，这里有店面，就在这里有一个古色古香的大招牌，上面写着“香槟”，有女酒保在供应香槟。这里有很多英国的，哦天哪，海伦，到处都是英国国旗。挂满了天花板。它看起来像一条街道的电影布景。街道的名字叫作
Nickelbee Road, Cratchits Yard, Pickwick Place, Fesiewigs Dance Party. We do have a map. Can't paint a map. So we're on Nickelbee Road right now. By Charles Dickens' house. The streets are thronging with people in different interpretations of Dickensian costume. Not compulsory for attendees, but encouraged. Oh yeah, that baby is like wrapped in a potato sack. That man actually took his baby, put their nonex face wrapped in a potato sack and brought him to the Dickens man. The Dickens Fairs London is also inhabited by scores of volunteers in well-research period
尼克尔比路（Nickelby Road）、克拉奇特庭院（Cratchit Yard）、皮克威克广场（Pickwick Place）、费斯威格舞会（Fesiewigs Dance Party）。我们确实有一张地图。画不出地图。所以我们现在在尼克尔比路上。在查尔斯·狄更斯故居旁。街上挤满了穿着各种对狄更斯时代服饰不同解读的人们。对参会者不是强制性的，但鼓励穿着。哦，是的，那个婴儿就像是被包裹在土豆袋里。那个男人实际上把他的婴儿，把他们没见过的脸包裹在土豆袋里，带到了狄更斯集市。狄更斯集市的伦敦还居住着许多穿着经过深入研究的历史服装的志愿者，
costumes. Before the event, they've been taught relevant history, given vocabulary guidelines and chosen names from a selection of approved Dickensian names. Oh, sorry, do you want to tell us your names? Oh, yeah. Or Tens, Snevalecki. The theatrical family, Snevalecki's. Oh, and there were English accents,
活动前，他们被传授了相关的历史知识，获得了词汇指南，并从精选的获批狄更斯时代名字中选择了自己的名字。哦，抱歉，你想告诉我们你们的名字吗？哦，是的。奥滕斯，斯内瓦莱基。戏剧家族，斯内瓦莱基家族。哦，还有英国口音，
which I thought were right. You go straight down and say, yeah, hit the docks. And if you go any further, you're gonna hit the Thames. You don't want to hit the Thames. And there's a Thames here. Well, of course there's a Thames.
我觉得很地道。你直走，然后说，去码头。如果你再往前走，你就会撞见泰晤士河。你可不想撞见泰晤士河。这里有一条泰晤士河。好吧，当然有一条泰晤士河。
We're in London, you silly fool. Please, please, please, he's from any light. I don't know, but they're giving me that look that says, ooh oh you've been having a little too much of Lord and no maven, June this day. Lord Anum was not a controlled substance in 19th century Britain, but it is now, so the Dickensphere doesn't sell it, but there are lots of places to buy tea and ale. There are performance stages, a fencing academy, shops, lots of shops. Draw the news, fine hats and bonnets.
我们是在伦敦，你这个大傻瓜。请，请，请，他是从……我不知道，但他们给我那种眼神，意思是：“哦，噢，你今天已经吃了不少鸦片酊（laudanum）了吧。”在19世纪的英国，鸦片酊并不是一种受控物质，但现在是了，所以狄更斯集市不卖它，但有很多地方可以买到茶和麦酒。这里有表演舞台、击剑学院、商店，还有很多商店。招揽生意，漂亮的帽子和女帽。
I've been wanting a bonnet. Really? No. Shop selling Victorianas such as corsets, jewelry, pies, and ones. Hang on, ones. Right, okay, well I don't really know where that's come from. Historian Greg Jenner has visited the illusionist before. In the episode Xmas Man he talked about the history of Santa Claus and Victorian Christmas cards with dead mice and bacon on them.
我一直想要一顶女帽。真的吗？不。出售维多利亚时代物品的商店，如紧身胸衣、珠宝、馅饼和魔杖。等等，魔杖？好吧，我真的不知道这玩意儿是从哪儿来的。历史学家格雷格·詹纳（Greg Jenner）以前参观过“幻术师”。在《圣诞老人》那一集中，他谈到了圣诞老人的历史以及上面画着死老鼠和培根的维多利亚时代圣诞卡。
Greg knows a lot about history and a lot about the history of Christmas. So I'll send to check a few things at the Dickensware to see whether or not they are Dickensian. I don't think magic ones particularly Dickensian, but I may be wrong on that. They're $15 each. Yeah, I guess that's just Harry Potter rolling over into some other season, isn't it? We've got a lot of ones left. What else is British? Dickens that'll do.
格雷格对历史了解很多，对圣诞节的历史也了解很多。所以我要去狄更斯集市核实几件事，看看它们是否具有狄更斯特色。我觉得魔法棒并不是特别有狄更斯特色，但我可能在这方面搞错了。它们每个15美元。是的，我想这只是哈利·波特延伸到了其他季节，对吧？我们还剩很多魔杖。还有什么是英国的？狄更斯，这就行了。
Or perhaps someone just mixed up their David Copperfields. There's a lot of commitment here. It's just interesting to see this many people go there, you know, like playing make-believe mixed up their David Copperfields. Yes, Top Hat Snow Problem at all. I mean, this is obviously the era of both Dickens and Abe Lincoln, both of whom were Top hat-efficient Ardors. Happy Christmas! Hey, why does no one say Merry Christmas? That's an American sort of thing.
或者也许有人把他们的《大卫·科波菲尔》搞混了。这里有很高的投入度。看到这么多人来这里，你知道的，就像玩假扮游戏，把《大卫·科波菲尔》搞混了，这很有趣。是的，大礼帽，完全没问题。我的意思是，这显然是狄更斯和亚伯拉罕·林肯的时代，这两位都是大礼帽的狂热爱好者。圣诞快乐！嘿，为什么没有人说“Merry Christmas”？那是美国人的说法。
Only happy Christmas. Great, happy Christmas to Kenjian, Merry Christmas, non-Dekensian. Seasons greetings were very varied in Victorian times. It's Merry Christmas and happy Christmas and season greetings and happy Yuletide and biblical quotations and lines from carols. So frankly there's no real wrong way to say happy Christmas or Merry Christmas in a Victorian fair other than saying cowabunga Christmas which would be obviously completely inappropriate. Are there particular words or phrases that are like,
只有“Happy Christmas”。太棒了，“Happy Christmas”是狄更斯式的，“Merry Christmas”是非狄更斯式的。维多利亚时代的节日问候非常多样化。有“Merry Christmas”和“Happy Christmas”，有节日问候（Season's greetings），有快乐的冬至（Happy Yuletide），还有圣经名言和颂歌中的台词。所以坦率地说，在维多利亚时代的集市上，说“Happy Christmas”或“Merry Christmas”并没有真正错误的说法，除非说“夏威夷果圣诞快乐”（cowabunga Christmas），那显然完全不合时宜。有没有特定的词汇或短语，比如，
I'm trying to keep you useful to stay in that art that you learned? Bollocks is wonderful. Like that was Bollocks! There's one guy, the Bollocks, not Bollocks guy. You know, he has a sign that says you're either Bollocks or you're not Bollocks. And then he, people walk by like, you're a Bollocks. He's like, I walked by and he said you're Bollocks when the baby's not Bollocks. Greg, the word Bollocks? Well, I mean, that's a good old English swear word. I don't know if the top of my head if Dickens ever used it in his novels, perhaps he did.
我想让你保持实用，留在你学到的那个时代？“Bollocks”（胡扯/废话）太棒了。就像那是“Bollocks”！有一个家伙，是个“Bollocks”先生，不是“Bollocks”这个词的那个。你知道，他举着一个牌子，上面写着“要么你是Bollocks，要么你不是Bollocks”。然后他，人们走过时就像，你是个Bollocks。他就说，我走过去时他说你是Bollocks，而那个婴儿不是Bollocks。格雷格，“Bollocks”这个词？好吧，我的意思是，这是一个古老的英国脏话。我脑子里记不清狄更斯是否在他的小说中使用过它，也许他用过。
But, I mean, it's got a long history. It goes all the way back to Anglo-Saxon English barks. So, if your festival is all about sort of quaint British-ness, then bollocks is our standard go-to English insult. It's our quaintest swear. I think so, isn't it? There's this one alley where everyone was dressed up as like a beggar or a prostitute or I guess a,
但是，我的意思是，它有着悠久的历史。它一直追溯到盎格lu-撒克逊英语“barks”。所以，如果你的节日完全是关于那种古雅的英国风情，那么“bollocsk”就是我们标准的常用英国侮辱语。这是我们最古雅的脏话。我想是的，对吧？有这样一条小巷，每个人都打扮得像乞丐或妓女，或者我猜，
what is it? The artful dodger is a pickpocket. Yeah, and pickpockets, and chimney sweeps. Like, there are a lot of people who have faked mud on their faces here. Which is kind of a weird thing, they're like dressed up as a porpoise. It wouldn't be my chosen form of escapism on the weekend, sure. But... Being rich is expensive and hard, and you have to do boring things.
那是什么？机灵鬼（Artful Dodger）是个扒手。是的，还有扒手，以及烟囱清扫工。就像，有很多人在脸上化了假泥。这有点奇怪，他们打扮得像海豚。这肯定不是我在周末时选择的逃避现实的方式。不过……富有是昂贵且艰难的，你必须做一些无聊的事情。
And when you're a scam, you get to gamble and gamble and drink and scream a lot and it's really fun. But I think we completely underestimate the terrifying daily stresses and strains of not having enough food, of having sexual violence if you're a woman who was a sex worker, of the diseases, you diseases, the infant mortality rates, the fact that children are working in factories and now pickpocketing on the streets, the lack of educational reform, there is an enormous canvas of sadness, of human sadness, which Dickens picks up on,
而当你是个无赖时，你可以赌博、赌博、喝酒、大喊大叫，这真的很有趣。但我认为我们完全低估了食物不足、作为性工作者的女性遭受性暴力、疾病、疾病、婴儿死亡率、儿童在工厂工作以及现在在街头当扒手、缺乏教育改革所带来的可怕日常压力和紧张，狄更斯所捕捉到的人类悲剧的画布是如此之大，
but there's a strange romance to it, which we seem to revel in. And I don't quite know why that is. Yeah, what was the life expectancy? Oh, incredibly poor, really poor. The average life expectancy in 1820 was perhaps something like 40 years old, and now we're closer to 80. The fact of a course that's contributing to that is massive infant mortality rates. You have a really high chance of having at least two children die on you if you have a family of six or seven kids. Women would frequently
但其中有一种奇怪的浪漫色彩，而我们似乎对此津津乐道。我不太明白这是为什么。是的，当时的预期寿命是多少？哦，糟透了，真的糟透了。1820年的平均预期寿命大概是40岁左右，而现在我们接近80岁。造成这种情况的一个重要原因当然是极高的婴儿死亡率。如果你有六七个孩子的一个家庭，你至少有两个孩子夭折的几率非常高。女性经常
have very serious illnesses in childbirth. More often than not, the thing that would kill a woman would be complications from childbirth. For men, of course, you have the military service being particularly dangerous in the age of the British Empire, which is off traveling the world and conquering things in a ruthless fashion. But also, of course, you have terrible diseases and no understanding of germ theory until the 1850s and 60s. So there are horrible cholera outbreaks that people don't understand. What spreads cholera, there is scurvy, there is dysentery, there is typhoid, just terrible deprivation, that people are able to feed themselves, unable to have healthy diets, there is chalk in the bread, you know, it's this is a period of
在分娩时患上非常严重的疾病。往往会夺去女性生命的是分娩并发症。当然，对于男性来说，在大英帝国的时代，兵役尤其危险，因为帝国四处征战，以残酷的方式征服事物。但当然，还有可怕的疾病，在1850年代和60年代之前对细菌理论一无所知。所以会有可怕的霍乱爆发，人们并不理解。是什么传播了霍乱，有坏血病，有痢疾，有伤寒，只是可怕的剥夺，人们无法养活自己，无法拥有健康的饮食，面包里有粉笔，你知道的，这是一个历史时期，
history where you can die of an ear infection or you can die of a scratch on your wrist, anything can get infected. So, it's really not a very nice time to be living if you don't have quite a lot of money. And even if you do have money, you might still die young. As happened to several of Dickens' closest relatives. Okay, let's go see if we can peek in. We're getting close to the house of Charles Dickens where
如果你没有很多钱，你可能会死于耳部感染，或者死于手腕上的抓伤，任何东西都会被感染。所以，如果你没有很多钱，这真的不是一个生活的好时代。即使你有钱，你也可能会英年早逝。就像狄更斯几位最亲近的亲属遭遇的那样。好了，让我们去看看能不能偷看一下。我们正在接近查尔斯·狄更斯的家，
he's writing, you can see in the window how he's writing. Goodness. What is he writing? Could be one of his 20 novels and novellas, dozens of short stories, articles and plays. But given the environment, there's quite a high possibility that he's writing something about Christmas. A Christmas Carol wasn't his first Christmas story, but it was such a hit that like Mariah Carey re-releasing all I want for Christmas is you each year afterwards there was pressure for Dickens to keep supplying festive material. His other Christmas stories, the chimes, the cricket on the
他在写作，你可以在窗户里看到他是如何写作的。天哪。他在写什么？可能是他的20部长篇和中篇小说、几十篇短篇小说、文章和戏剧中的一部。但鉴于这种环境，他写关于圣诞节的东西的可能性相当高。《圣诞颂歌》并不是他的第一个圣诞故事，但它是如此大获成功，就像玛丽亚·凯莉（Maria Carey）在之后每年的圣诞节重新发行《All I Want for Christmas Is You》一样，狄更斯面临着持续提供节日素材的压力。他的其他圣诞故事还有《钟声》、《炉边蟋蟀》、《生活之战》、《鬼魂与幽灵的交易》。他还为《家庭世界》（Household Worlds）撰稿，这是他的一种杂志。每年7月，他就会开始为该杂志的圣诞特刊创作故事。
half, the battle of life, the haunted man and the Half, the Battle of Life, the Haunted Man and the Ghosts Bargain. He also writes in Household Worlds, which is his sort of magazine. He'd be working on stories for the Christmas edition of the magazine from July of each year. There's the Christmas tree, a Christmas dinner. There's a very sad essay written in 1851, the year in which four of his family members die, called What Christmas Is as We Grow Older, which is a kind of tribute to them, but also a calling out in defense of Christmas and saying Christmas is about looking forward and hoping for a better future while at the same time remembering those who've gone before.
有《圣诞树》、《圣诞晚餐》。1851年，他写了一篇非常悲伤的文章，那一年他的四个家庭成员去世了，名叫《随着我们长大的圣诞节是什么》（What Christmas Is as We Grow Older），这既是对他们的致敬，也是对圣诞节的呼吁和捍卫，并表示圣诞节是关于展望未来、希望有更美好的未来，同时也缅怀那些逝去的人。
So he returns to Christmas many times in his career and indeed a great expectation starts with a Christmas scene, but none of those matched the success of a Christmas Carol. A Christmas Carol is by far and away his best, his most defiantly popular and most influential Christmas story. How many other books have been adapted hundreds of times for film and TV? The popularity of a Christmas Carol has never waned. It was an absolute smash hit straight away. It was published on 19 December 1843,
所以在他的职业生涯中，他多次回归圣诞节，事实上《远大前程》也是从一个圣诞场景开始的，但没有一个能比得上《圣诞颂歌》的成功。毫无疑问，《圣诞颂歌》是他最好、最具有标志性的人气最高、最具影响力的圣诞故事。还有多少其他书被改编成数百次电影和电视？《圣诞颂歌》的热度从未衰减。它一经出版就获得了绝对的轰动。它于1843年12月19日出版，
and by Christmas Eve it was already sold out. The next year the book was adapted several times for stage and reprinted and reprinted. It has never been out of print. Dickens did public readings of the book was adopted several times for stage and reprinted and reprinted. It has never been out of print. Dickens did public readings of the book in Britain and the US until his death in 1870. And beyond? Yeah, we're at Charles Dickens' house and where he will be doing a reading. But this is a very elaborate house. It's like completely set up like a full interior.
到平安夜时已经售罄。第二年，这本书被多次搬上舞台，并不断再版。它从未绝版。狄更斯在英国和美国公开朗读这本书，直到1870年他去世。甚至在他去世之后？是的，我们在查尔斯·狄更斯的故居，他将在这里进行朗读。但这是一栋非常精致的房子。它完全布置得像一个完整的室内空间。
And there's like a swimming couch and a fireplace and a bookshelf. Chachkis all over the place, pictures on the wall, rugs, full nine yards. This exterior is painted like stone. So Charles Dickens wearing a long black coat is standing at a rib podium, reading dramatically, from a Christmas Carol, to a crowd that has gathered and costumed a non-costumed people sitting in his house. He's very enthused, he's like going beyond the podium. He's leaning into the audience, he's using his hands,
里面有贵妃椅、壁炉和书架。到处都是小饰品，墙上有画，有地毯，应有尽有。这个外观被画得像石头一样。所以身穿长黑大衣的查尔斯·狄更斯站在一个雕花讲台旁，充满戏剧性地朗读着《圣诞颂歌》，台下聚集了身穿戏服和没穿戏服的人们，他们坐在他的房子里。他非常热情，甚至走出了讲台。他倾身向向观众，他用手势，
he's just accumulating. He's rude, said it with an harness, and he's not in a mistake. He clapped him on the back. I'm married, Christmas ball, and Mary, I'm Michael Federer. Then I'd give him you any money. What do you know about Charles Dickens, Katie Mingle?
他只是在积累。他粗鲁地说，带着挽具，他没有犯错。他拍了拍他的背。我结婚了，圣诞球，和玛丽，我是迈克尔·费德勒。然后我会给你任何钱。你对查尔斯·狄更斯了解多少，凯蒂·明格尔？
So little. I was in a production of Oliver once. But Dickens is one of those authors whose work you kind of know without even having read it. Some authors work sticks so much in cultural consciousness, their name becomes an adjective, Kafkaesque or Wellian, Dickensian. Well Dickensian is a very, very broad idea. There's an incredibly vast canvas of what we think of as Dickensian. And even though we use it as a word, that word itself has so many different interpretations
少得可怜。我曾经参演过一次《雾都孤儿》。但狄更斯就是那种即使你没读过，也仿佛对他的作品有所了解的作家。有些作家的作品深深烙印在文化意识中，他们的名字变成了一个形容词，比如卡夫卡式的（Kafkaesque）、奥威尔式的（Orwellian）、狄更斯式的（Dickensian）。嗯，“狄更斯式的”是一个非常非常广泛的概念。在我们看来，属于狄更斯式的事物的画布极其广阔。尽管我们把它当作一个词来使用，但这个词本身有着如此多的不同解释
and meanings. Men with muffin chop sideburns and stovepipe hats, women with hearts of gold and tragically short lives, orphans fending for themselves while menacing adults lurk around every corner, please, Sarah, I want some more! And Christmas, many Christmas! Christmas goose, Christmas ghosts! God bless us, everyone! Dickensian is quite a tricky word, actually,
和含义。留着大胡子鬓角、戴着烟囱高帽的男人，有着金子般的心、生命短暂得令人唏嘘的女性，在各个角落都有威胁成年人潜伏的情况下自力更生的孤儿，“求您了，先生，我还要一点！”还有圣诞节，很多圣诞节！圣诞鹅，圣诞鬼魂！愿上帝保佑我们每一个人！其实“狄更斯式的”是一个相当棘手的词，
and I think we don't always necessarily know what we mean when we say it. As a word, it kind of conjures up poverty, perhaps, a sense of squalor, a sense of people trapped in this sort of brutal society where there is no safety net, there is no full-back plan where children and young women can suddenly be cast into a life of poverty or crime or violence. But Dickens, you know, also really should sum up some of the beautiful things, some of the wonderful things he harnesses, you know, when we look at a Christmas Carol, the way he depicts the street scenes and
我想我们在说这个词时，并不总是清楚自己究竟想表达什么。作为一个词，它可能会让人联想到贫困，一种肮脏的感觉，一种人们被困在这样一个残酷社会中的感觉，那里没有安全网，没有退路，儿童和年轻女性会突然陷入贫困、犯罪或暴力的生活。但你知道，狄更斯也确实总结了一些美好的事物，他所驾驭的一些精彩事物，你知道，当我们看《圣诞颂歌》时，他描绘街头场景的方式，以及
the sort of children and people singing and saying hello to each other, the sense of community, the shop windows filled to the brim with delicious goods and treats to eat on Christmas day and toys in the window. You know, this is also a bountiful visual iconography. Dickens conjured up both quite alarming and also quite enrapturing and trancing visions of what a city and a community could be. So Dickensian tends to be quite negative but it really should, I suppose, apply to all of the different worlds that Dickens created. And some of those were rather pleasant and lovely, and some of those were rather cruel and dark. Yeah, like what's the deal with Christmas?
那种孩子们和人们唱歌、互相打招呼的场景，社区的感，圣诞节那天摆满美味佳肴和零食的商店橱窗，以及橱窗里的玩具。你知道，这也是一幅丰饶的视觉图像。狄更斯唤起了人们对城市和社区可能模样的既令人惊恐又令人陶醉、着迷的愿景。所以“狄更斯式的”往往带有相当负面的色彩，但我想，它其实应该适用于狄更斯所创造的所有不同世界。其中有些相当愉快和可爱，而有些则相当残酷和黑暗。是的，圣诞节是怎么回事？
Against? Yeah. A lot of authors have written about Christmas, but don't have festive fares devoted to them. Why does Dickens get to be the adjective? Why has he given credit for Christmas? You know, one of the things people often say is Dickens invented Christmas, which is absolute nonsense, of course he didn't. A child's Dickens' Christmas is not brand new in 1843.
针对什么？是的。许多作家都写过关于圣诞节的文章，但并没有专门为他们设立节日集市。为什么狄更斯能成为形容词？为什么圣诞节的功劳要归于他？你知道，人们常说的一件事是狄更斯发明了圣诞节，这绝对是无稽之谈，他当然没有。查尔斯·狄更斯的圣诞节在1843年并不是全新的。
He perpetuated some traditions. He reinvigorated others. There had been Christmas for centuries. There had been traditions that he had grown up with as a child. That he perpetuated and shared in his books. Singing, feasting, charitable donations. That's all medieval, chewed, stewed, georgian, whatever you want to call it. So Dickens is not the architect. He's a cheerleader.
他延续了一些传统。他重振了其他传统。几个世纪以来一直都有圣诞节。有他小时候伴随着长大的传统。他在书中延续并分享了这些传统。唱歌、饕餮大餐、慈善捐款。这些都是中世纪的、炖出来的、乔治时代的，无论你想怎么称呼它。所以狄更斯不是建筑师。他是个啦啦队长。
Very different professions. Well, maybe, maybe so. I mean, they both build large structures don't they? A Christmas Carol landed at a time when there was a trend for nostalgia. The 19th century is an era where you have many folklorists and antiquarians taking an interest in the old ways. There is definitely in the 19th century this idea of a mythologised past of the Tudor era being the sort of housey on days. Just as we have the Dickensian festivals in San Francisco and we look back to the Victorians, the Victorians looked back to the Saxons and the Normans and the Tudors as a kind of glory days of simplicity where the good old
完全不同的职业。好吧，也许，也许吧。我的意思是，他们都建造宏大的结构，不是吗？《圣诞颂歌》问世时正值怀旧风潮兴起。19世纪是一个涌现出许多民俗学家和古董商对旧习俗感兴趣的时代。19世纪绝对有这样一种神话般的都铎时代是黄金时代的观念。正如我们在旧金山举办狄更斯节并回顾维多利亚时代一样，维多利亚时代的人们回首萨克森人、诺曼人和都铎人，将其视为一个简朴的荣耀时代，那时美好的旧
days of Christmas were much more pleasant. Because in some ways the Victorian Christmas is a reaction to industrialisation, the trauma of enormous economic thrust of people moving from the countryside into the cities, of communities being broken up, of dark satanic meals, of factories, of trains and industry, of the British Empire expanding and people being separated by huge geographical distances. Not only that, a Christmas Carol was riding a wave of renewed interest in Christmas, so along with the revival of older festive customs, there were new ones emerging that decade too.
圣诞节要愉快得多。因为在某些方面，维多利亚时代的圣诞节是对工业化的一种反应，是对人们从乡村涌入城市、社区被打破、黑暗的撒旦磨坊、工厂、火车和工业所带来巨大经济冲击的创伤的反应，也是对大英帝国扩张和人们被巨大的地理距离隔开的反应。不仅如此，《圣诞颂歌》顺应了人们对圣诞节重新燃起兴趣的潮流，因此除了复兴更古老的节日习俗之外，那十年里也有新的习俗涌现。
Christmas cards were suddenly logistically viable, with the invention of the penny post in 1840. Christmas trees also became popular around then. King George III's German wife had introduced them to Britain in the late 1700s, so they weren't completely new, but they were newly fashionable when, in 1848, Queen Victoria, Prince Albert and their children posed in front of theirs for the illustrated London news. And like when whatever Cape Middleton wears sells out, Christmas trees became all the rage. So quite a lot of traditions, what we think of as traditions now, that we assume a Dakenzian, they're not Dakenzian,
随着1840年便士邮政的发明，圣诞卡突然在后勤上变得可行了。圣诞树也在那时变得流行起来。乔治三世国王的德国妻子在18世纪末将它们引入了英国，所以它们并不是完全崭新的，但在1848年，维多利亚女王、阿尔伯特亲王和他们的孩子为《伦敦画报》在圣诞树前摆好姿势时，它们成了新时尚。就像凯特·米德尔顿穿什么就会卖光一样，圣诞树风靡一时。所以相当多的传统，我们现在认为是传统的东西，我们以为是狄更斯式的，其实并不是狄更斯式的，
they just arrive at exactly the same time through pure coincidence. And it's all mushed together. And this Victorian festival suddenly feels like it's this brand new thing, but it's not. It's a continuity with some extra additional elements and the capitalism ramps it all up. Christmas is a commercial economy without parallel. It's incredibly capitalistic. It had been for a while, but in the 19th century it becomes more so. And you see the emergence of Christmas magazines, Christmas books, Christmas toys for children, which is a new market that's just sort of opening up. But Dickens' main intention wasn't to cash in on Christmas.
它们只是纯粹巧合地在同一时期出现。这一切都被混在了一起。这个维多利亚时代的集市突然让人感觉这是一个全新事物，但其实不然。它具有连续性，带有一些额外的元素，而资本主义则把这一切推向了高潮。圣诞节是一个无与伦比的商业经济体。它极具资本主义色彩。它已经这样一段时间了，但在19世纪它变得更加如此。你可以看到圣诞杂志、圣诞书、给儿童的圣诞玩具的出现，这是一个刚刚开始开拓的新市场。但狄更斯的主要目的并不是为了从圣诞节中捞钱。
I mean, he did need the money. Though he had had considerable literary success the previous decade, lately the serialization of his novel Martin Chuzzlewitt hadn't been too popular and his income was looking dicey, plus he had a growing family to support and was often bailing out his parents and siblings too. And Dickens did sincerely love Christmas, his children wrote about the relish with which their father approached the festivities each year, but that wasn't the primary motivation either. Instead, his heartwarming Christmas fable was the cover story for a political mission. He was a man who had a tremendous political appetite and who was of the middle classes and, of course, befriended the upper classes, but was always on the side of the working classes.
我的意思是，他确实需要钱。尽管他在上一个十年里取得了相当大的文学成功，但最近他的小说《马丁·查盖利特》的连载并不是很受欢迎，他的收入看起来有些不确定，而且他还要抚养不断扩大的家庭，还经常为父母和兄弟姐妹还债。狄更斯也确实真心喜爱圣诞节，他的孩子们曾写下他们的父亲每年接近节日时的热情，但这也不是主要的动机。相反，他那温馨的圣诞寓言是一个政治使命的掩护。他是一个有着巨大政治热忱的人，属于中产阶级，当然也结交上流阶层，但始终站在工人阶级一边。
And this, of course, was largely because he'd experienced poverty as a child. Dickens was the second of eight children in a pretty close family and had what he considered to be an adilic childhood until he was aged 11, whereupon his father, who regularly had financial problems, was sent to prison for debt. And as was custom at the time,
当然，这很大程度上是因为他童年时经历过贫困。狄更斯是一个关系相当紧密的家庭中八个孩子里的老二，拥有他认为田园诗般的童年，直到他11岁时，经常面临财务问题的父亲因债务被送进监狱。按照当时的习俗，
Dickens' mother and younger siblings moved in there with him. For a year, Charles Dickens lived alone. He had to quit school and worked 10 our days, six days a week at a boot-blocking factory. Though the family did reunite, the experience stayed with Dickens, informing much of his work and political attitudes. He is a man who's always championing those who've had a less fortunate life.
狄更斯的母亲和弟弟妹妹们和他一起搬到那里。整整一年，查尔斯·狄更斯独自生活。他不得不辍学，在一个鞋油厂每周工作六天，每天工作十小时。虽然全家人最终团聚了，但这段经历一直留在狄更斯心中，并构成了他许多作品和政治态度的基础。他是一个总是为生活不幸的人仗义执言的人。
He campaigned against public executions, he thought they were vile and grim. You know, he campaigned for women, he campaigned for better schooling for children. He's a man who uses his voice as a campaigning tool. Though in the Victorian area, Britannia rolled the waves, colored the globe pink, et cetera. At home, many people were destitute. Industrial revolution had ushered in such huge societal
他发起反对公开处决的运动，他认为那极其残忍且阴暗。你知道的，他为女性发起运动，为儿童争取更好的教育而奔走。他是一个把自己的声音当作宣传工具的人。尽管在维多利亚时代，大英帝国威震四海，将全球版图染成粉红色，等等。在国内，许多人却一贫如洗。工业革命在那个世纪带来了巨大的社会
and economic changes that century, but welfare and health services had not been instituted yet. And Dickens was horrified by the poverty so many people were stricken by in 1843, particularly the conditions children were living in, on the streets, in schools for the impoverished, working down mines or in factories as he had done himself, and he was desperate to make a palpable difference. As a journalist, he planned to write a political pamphlet about it, entitled, An Appeal to the People of England for the Benefit of the Poor Man's Child, but he realised that not many people would read a political pamphlet.
和经济变革，但福利和健康服务尚未建立。1843年，许多人陷入贫困之中，特别是儿童在街头、在贫民学校的生活状况，以及像他自己曾经做过的那样在矿井或工厂里工作的情景，让狄更斯感到震惊，他迫切希望能带来切实可见的改变。作为一名记者，他原本计划写一篇题为《呼吁英国人民为了穷人的孩子的利益》的政治小册子，但他意识到没有多少人会读政治小册子。
They would, however, read his fiction. And as a spoonful of sugar helps the medicine go down, Dickens coated his plea for social justice with a feel good Christmas ghost story. And so Dickens, you know, later on would write many, many journalistic pieces and editorials and he would use his power as a journalist and an essayist, but with a Christmas Carol, he's using his power as a sentimental novelist to move people to action, to inspire them, to be better Christians, to be better British people, to be better neighbors, family members, lovers, friends,
然而，他们会读他的小说。正如良药苦口需要糖浆调味一样，狄更斯用一个温馨的圣诞鬼故事将他对社会公正的呼吁包裹起来。因此，你知道的，狄更斯后来写了许许多多的新闻报道和社论，他会利用自己作为记者和散文家的力量，但在《圣诞颂歌》中，他利用的是自己作为感伤小说家的力量，去激励人们采取行动，鼓舞他们成为更好的基督徒、更好的英国人、更好的邻居、家庭成员、爱人、朋友、
co-workers, colleagues, et cetera. It's a book about charity, and it's a book about community, and about what happens when the ravages of capitalism erode the human spirit and they corrupt the heart of Scrooge? You know, he was a man who once felt, who once cared, who once loved, and ultimately over the years he's been sort of gradually worn down by this Victorian urge to make profit, you know, economy, industrial progress, moving forward, and he's lost his humanity to the point that his own family, you know, don't really want to hang out with him, they don't really know him.
同事等等。这是一本关于慈善的书，是一本关于社区的书，也是关于当资本主义的摧残侵蚀了人类精神并腐蚀了斯克鲁奇的心灵时会发生什么的书？你知道的，他曾是一个有感知、有爱心、懂得关怀的人，但最终多年来，他逐渐被维多利亚时代追求利润、经济、工业进步、向前发展的渴望所消磨，以至于他失去了人性，甚至连自己的家人，你知道的，都不太愿意跟他相处，他们根本不了解他。
He's lost all of his empathy for his fellow man. So a Christmas Carol is an allegory, a very Christian allegory, a deeply spiritual book about a man who has become lost finding his way back to his humanity. And Dickens' mission did succeed. Somewhat, the book was credited with causing a rise in charitable giving and greater generosity to your fellow humans and employees at Christmas. But it couldn't totally transform society. Literature can move us, but ultimately,
他失去了对同胞的所有同理心。所以，《圣诞颂歌》是一个寓言，一个非常具有基督教色彩的寓言，一本关于一个迷失自我的人找回人性的深具灵性的书。狄更斯的使命确实成功了。某种程度上，这本书被认为引发了圣诞节期间慈善捐赠的增加，以及对同胞和雇员更多的慷慨。但它并不能彻底改变社会。文学可以触动我们，但归根结底，
structural systems are very hard to shift. And the Victorian period had many, many years of moving forward and very small steps being taken with children's rights or educational reforms and so on. But the rights of women in particular. The Christmas aspect may have overwhelmed the political message. Though the sentiment to be kind to fellow humans hasn't been lost, it's there in all the screen adaptations, even the ones riffing on the story, like scrooge, or running a little
结构性系统非常难以撼动。维多利亚时代经历了多年的向前发展，但在儿童权利或教育改革等方面只迈出了很小的步伐。特别是女性的权利。圣诞节的元素可能掩盖了政治信息。尽管善待同胞的情感并未丢失，它存在于所有的银幕改编中，甚至是在这个故事上进行戏谑的版本，比如《小气财神》，或者更进一步进行改编的作品，比如《坏圣诞老人》。
further away with the inspiration, like Bad Santa. But I tell you what, I reread it this week and the original still works a treat. Because it's a really readable book. The characters leap off the page and it's really moving and inspiring and you desperately hope that Scrooge stays reformed. It's really funny as well. I think one of the disadvantages to the word de Kenzian is that it makes his work sound like it's going to be stodgy as a Christmas pudding boiled for eight hours, but it's not a cozy period piece. His book is a reaction to the economic situation in the 1840s, so his book is deeply modern and yet his outlook, his attitudes, his sense of nostalgia and whimsy is of course in many ways deeply traditional.
但我告诉你，我这周重读了一遍，原著依然精彩绝伦。因为这是一本极具可读性的书。书中人物跃然纸上，非常感人且催人奋进，你会迫切希望斯克鲁奇保持改过自新的状态。而且它也非常有趣。我认为“狄更斯式的”这个词的一个缺点是，它让他的作品听起来像是煮了八小时的圣诞布丁那样沉闷，但它并不是一部温馨的时代剧。他的书是对1840年代经济状况的一种回应，因此他的书极其现代，然而他的视角、他的态度、他的怀旧感和奇思妙想在很多方面当然又极其传统。
So he is bringing a kind of fusion between hyper-modernity and old-fashioned, old-timey, lovely nostalgia, days of your. And when we look back at Dickens, we do the same. The Illusionist is produced by Helen Zoltzman with music and production by Martin Ostwick. It is a member of Radio Topia and you should subscribe to it immediately and thank me for the suggestion, while the link on the website and in the show notes. 99% invisible as a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco with produced on Radio Row in
因此，他带来了一种超现代主义与老派、旧时光、迷人的怀旧情调——逝去岁月的融合。当我们回顾狄更斯时，我们也在做同样的事。《幻术师》由海伦·佐尔特曼制作，音乐和制作由马丁·奥斯特威克负责。它是Radiotopia的成员，你应该立即订阅它，并为我的建议感谢我，相关链接在网站和节目笔记中。《99%隐形》是旧金山91.7KALW的项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。
beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collection of fiercely independent and fascinating podcasts. Find them all at radioiotopia.fm. We had a really good year of shows, and I hope you heard them all, but if you didn't, you can subscribe and listen to them all at 99pi.org. Radio TV from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是来自PRX的Radiotopia的自豪成员，这是一个由极其独立且迷人的播客组成的集合。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。我们度过了非常精彩的一年节目，我希望你都听过了，如果你还没听，可以在99pi.org上订阅并收听所有节目。来自PRX的Radio TV。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。